been weird we're kind of a format
agnostic that is true but what was like
uh for you like how many years in is
this you did it
what do you mean you did it
you see that you look at him smiling he
knows it you did it you remember i
remember we're eating tacos
outside of st taco bus in saint pete
florida and saint pete florida and we
were 14 yeah i was out here in la doing
the uh doing this doing the shimmy shuck
at the time and trying to figure it out
and i'd had the record sunday morning
yep before uncle cracker was before
uncle cracker was on it when it was just
an acoustic strip down record and you
were like
what the [ __ ] are you doing you was like
go all you just like started preaching
to me at this little taco bus and you
were like bet the farm on this [ __ ] this
is what you need to do this is it this
you were just like ringing it home i
can't remember rich was with us that
time or not but i know we've seen rich
in the same circuit around that time
and i was like i left there thinking
like
all right [ __ ] it i'm gonna just and i
did i just went all the way in yeah that
sunday morning record was crazy it's
still crazy let's do it so fire i love
that song it's yeah i like the like the
og version that you would just play me
no for sure it was like a real
it was unplugged right it was like just
literally brought in i mean saved me
yeah for sure exactly
literally
i got something i'll play before we
leave i got something i want to play i'm
so excited about oh i bet uh
yeah that was like in 2000 that was like
2014. that was like when you uh what was
the name of that white dude who would
always book all all y'all in in uh saint
pete [ __ ] kev kevin
yeah i just seen big kev when we went
down there and played uh there what was
the rock fest um
if we played the rock guy they're gonna
hate me
[ __ ] forgive me y'all i'm hungover
i'm day hung over
um it's different in the day yeah it's
so different when you got drunk at 9am
but
we played no no that we played that one
after that but it was the tampa rock
station
yes rockfest or something whatever the
name of that station was down there in
tampa the rock station [ __ ] if anybody
should know you should know what's the
name of the right it's only rock station
something x 98 x i think yeah max might
have been x fest or something like that
that sounds about right yeah whatever
yeah hey it rhymes we kicked it we had a
ball but anyways yeah we i just i just
seen big kevin came out to see us there